il est 19h l'air de repos de limours
briis-sous-forges sur l'autoroute a10 se
remplit de camions en première ligne
dans la crise sanitaire les chauffeurs
de poids lourds assure la majorité de
l'activité des structures autoroutières
dans ce contexte vinci a noué un
partenariat avec ce traiteur yvelinois
chaque soir il sert en moyenne 30 à 35
repas gratuits aux routiers soir c'est
la blanquette avec du riz a pas une
petite mousse au chocolat ils ont à
coeur de baguettes de pain une bouteille
d'eau et puis voilà ça sent porté il ya
découvert il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour
manger dans le camion on est présent
mais pour aider les routiers finalement
à faire une pause agréable ont donc leur
offrir un repas chaud et puis et puis
aussi et surtout leur permettre de
recharger leurs flacons de gel
hydroalcoolique
ils sont actuellement en première ligne
pour ravitailler tout un chacun
les employés du transport routier sont
soulagés de bénéficier de ce type de
service parfois ils se retrouvent dans
des situations compliquées
merci manger grand problème en face à
fabre monstres et la suisse
problème tous problèmes y'a rien à voir
autoroute problème ces conditions de
route aux gens sont aussi idéale sur un
camion qui roulait ça faut pas se voiler
la face
mais aujourd'hui
hésitation le soir en live c'est fermé
sur cette aire de repos la station
service reste ouverte 24 heures sur 24
les employés sont équipés pour assurer
leur mission offre alimentaire de
boissons chaudes et de carburant tous
les services habituels sont maintenues
avec quelques adaptations
généralement on est 3 4 le matin trois
quatre l'après midi on est passé à deux
personnes le matin de personnes l'après
midi et deux personnes la nuit en fête
pour avec un équilibre entre du
personnel d'entretien et le service en
fait
haute de vente en fait en caisse pour
une continuité d'activité en fait
aujourd'hui on travaille essentiellement
avec tous les chauffeurs routiers tous
les services d'urgence en fait qu'ils
peuvent passer par rapport au carburant
donc oui on est sur une tendance entre -
trop - 60 et -80% quand même sur le sur
le site quoi d'après les estimations du
groupe vinci autoroutes le trafic
autoroutier aurait diminué de 16% entre
le 1er et le 20 mars 2020